[Music]
what does it mean to have someone like
Beyonce to turn to at a time of need and
knowing that she is ready to step up
well she has one huge platform and
information can go out to places that
really need to know what's going on in
her hometown and she has always availed
not only her platform her voice but also
resources tangible resources to help
those in the most need here here in
Houston and around Beyonce's pasture
opening up to ET about how the superstar
has come through for her hometown of
Houston following the devastation of
Hurricane Harvey
when did she reach out to you about a
donation to help with relief work for
hurricane Harvey yesterday she did so we
are already rolling when Beyonce says
she's coordinating with you what does
that mean she's starting out with a with
a significant donation and that donation
is going to get us lunch out into some
areas that help us really more
effectively impact the communities that
have been most effective let me ask you
this do you expect to see her down there
anytime soon or any of her family
members there's no tellin she's got a
lot going on but she has already made
her presence known here in Houston
detected in many ways I am assuming at
some point that Beyonce may be her very
famous sister and also her husband could
be part of something that could help
have there been any kind of talks about
anything like that no talks yet but over
the over the years they have always been
present when when Hurricane Katrina hit
they were present for us when I
devastated Houston they were present for
it and and times in between so now won't
be any different I'm counting on them
right now how can people help we have a
website rent of life ich dot o-r-g
spread of life Inc that orgy people can
go to that website and make donations if
you're in Houston Texas
downtown Houston the the campus at st.
John's downtown we're easy to find in
the middle of downtown Houston to drop
off non-perishable and items if you know
that people will need to volunteer just
stop by and we're going to have people
ready to sign you up to get involved
[Music]